excusez moi les impôts mais ça vous
empêche pas de dormir de nous demander
de l'argent qu'on a déjà des plans très
haut qu'elle est grosse mais partie you
can see in japan yahoo trafic pin's
biarritz desseigne j'ai absolument pas
la vie que je mérite et je veux plus
jamais travailler et vous deviez épouser
un prince
monsieur zier qui j'étais vous
j'épouserai le prince harry d'angleterre
non le roux là elle est en route
je vais à londres
deux cars john green and write web en
dalles de shit
c'est là que la combine
cominar de côté sauf paris intra muros à
26 narry diplomate match hors zone ex
ornis
à
tu te calmes un témoin jeu tu pue de la
gueule donc tu restes assis
tranquillement stopper merci beaucoup
bataille de chiffres
2 3 tab du gept
aux chorégraphies vous a dit de faire
cette bouse
rita capte pas là j'ai pas de réseau
sont trop épais les murs